you have thoughts on just simply
finishing film mm-hmm what that means
yeah absolutely i think for especially
the aspiring level the kind of the
newbies or what have you and that's a
relative term i believe an artist is
always a newbie you're always striving
to get better but especially you know
the first few years of striving to get
good at an art form or a craft I believe
the first and foremost if not the only
goal ought to be completion production
actually making something that in and of
itself is a worthy goal and I believe
that in and of itself ought to be the
only goal for someone's first few
projects get Sundance out of your head
get sales out of your head get a fanbase
out of your head so all those things we
want get it out of your head you don't
deserve it you're probably not going to
get it let it go and even more
importantly most of the time it's out of
your control anyway your goal is
completion that's it and I like to say
something that isn't very popular not
even making a good film ought to be your
goal making the film is your goal in the
beginning stages and what I mean is you
may not even be capable of making a good
film your first few films you know I'm
not saying don't strive for excellence
I'm saying work hard do your best but
get that notion that qualitative notion
of a good film get it get that even out
of your head because all those things
are hindrances all those things are
going to bias you and create obstacles
in your development and your production
and they're going to get in the way of
what's the most important thing which is
producing which is making work which is
working on your craft and
getting good producing being a film
maker not a film talker the film thinker
you have being a film maker that's the
most important thing then after you've
made a few then you could say okay I
know how to make films now now I want to
kick it up a notch aesthetically
qualitatively okay now I've earned the
right to want to make a good film and
then maybe be in the future a great film
but you know put that aside for a while
you